[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
عندنا امطار شتاء وامطار صيف الشتويه تسبق
بامطار الهريف في شهر اغسطس والصيفيه تسبق
بامطار سبق السرايات في شهر مارس والهريف
والسبق هي امطار ممهده لها والهريف تتركز
على المناطق الجنوبيه واليمن وسلطنه عمان
والسرايات تتركز على اداء من الحجاز ونجد
والمنطقه الشرقيه والكويت ونحن الان على
عتبات موسم السرايات المسمى بامطار الصيف
وهي امطار متفرقه تكون في بقعه دون ثانيه
ومشوبه بحبات برد ولها صوت دبدبه وحبه
المطر كبيره ولاليه التهاطل لا تسال
الليله عن دمعي وعن وجعي ايسكونان وطيف
الراحلين معي ادري بهم رحلوا ما عاد لي
امل عقلي وعى غير ان القلب ليس
يعي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
والامطار الشتويه تنبت الربيع الشتوي وهو
نبت ناعم مثل الروض والنفل والامطار
الصيفيه تنبت الربيع الصيفي وهو شجر خشن
مثل الحمض وهل الاولين الله يرحمهم يهتمون
بالربيع الصيفي اكثر من الشتوي ليش لانه
يرعون به الحولي كامل اي سنتين كامله
ولهذا قالوا يا الله بصيفيه المرعى بها
حوليه ولا شتويه نرعى بها وسميه
[موسيقى]